[Music]
on this monday night russian missiles
rain down on ukraine's capital
the mountain carnage and kiev the
struggle to get people out of mariupol
and odessa braces for what's next
all eyes on a key russian ally the fears
moscow wants beijing's help we will not
allow any country to compensate russia
for its losses what's at stake for the
chinese government and the west seized
by squatters the storming of a mansion
linked to a russian billionaire and
fueling change how record high gas
prices we've just seen even further
shift are driving people away from the
traditional commute
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight david aiken
good evening and thank you for joining
us russian forces are continuing their
push towards the ukrainian capital
tonight
this map shows the current scale of the
offensive the areas in red outline
territory under russian control the
arrows indicate regions in which
russia's army is advancing and that
includes kiev where bombardments are
happening at a more rapid pace and the
civilian death toll is growing each day
as the attack intensifies the
humanitarian crisis is also worsening
and peace talks at resume today have
made little progress
mike armstrong is in ukraine where he
begins our coverage tonight and a
warning some of the images you're about
to see are disturbing
[Music]
those sounds of shelling have gotten
closer to kiev day by day
on this day they moved from the suburbs
to the city but it's almost more
haunting without those sounds a
surveillance video captures a man in
kiev out for a morning walk he hears
something overhead and then a massive
explosion
heavy artillery hit downtown for the
first time witnesses say two people were
killed in this attack when a projectile
hit the street
in this case an apartment building was
hit it started a fire two more people
were killed
president zielinski in an address shot
in downtown keefe says the weather may
be beautiful but ukrainians don't even
notice the skies aren't clear he says
over kiev or other cities
well these are shots taken from those
skies released monday from over mariupol
they show buildings in the port city on
fire mariupol is encircled by russian
forces ukraine says an aid convoy hasn't
been able to reach the city and they
haven't been able to move women and
children out
it says so far in mariupol 2500 people
have died
including this pregnant mother and her
unborn child injured last wednesday when
a maternity hospital was hit by shelling
[Applause]
in another coastal city preparations
there is fear an expected russian attack
could cut the city of odessa off from
the rest of ukraine to get ready
civilians are building defenses we work
here because
we don't know how to kill
we are not professional warriors but we
we can help our army
now that army took a sizable hit sunday
when the average base in western ukraine
was struck by eight russian missiles 35
people were killed and more than 130
injured as it turns out it was very
nearly much worse there was an alert
something was coming most of the base
had left their barracks and were in the
forest when the missiles hit
are they not me a military spokesman
tells global news the dead would have
numbered in the hundreds
now i spoke to a canadian foreign
fighter tonight here in la viv he didn't
want to appear on camera the code name
he's using while here is maple he said
he was in the barracks when those
missiles hit as it turns out he was just
lucky not to be in one that was hit
badly i asked him why he came here he
said he's had trouble watching people
accept what's going on here he couldn't
and wanted to come and join the fight
david
mike armstrong in ukraine thank you mike
the number of refugees who have left
ukraine is expected to hit 3 million
this week at about 100 000 people per
day fleeing the country that could
happen as soon as wednesday the world
health organization says about
6.7 million people have already been
displaced inside ukraine
russia is accusing ukraine of a cluster
bomb attack on the separatist region of
donetsk russia's defense ministry says
more than 20 people were killed in what
it is calling a war crime but ukraine
was quick to deny any involvement saying
the missile is in fact russian neither
claim has been independently verified
president vladimir zelensky's office
released a video of him visiting wounded
soldiers at an undisclosed location
in the video shared sunday zielinski
handed out medals to the soldiers
honoring their courage and dedication he
also recognized hospital staff for their
work zielinski is scheduled to deliver a
speech to canada's parliament tomorrow
and the u.s congress on wednesday
the world is also watching china very
closely u.s officials say russia has
asked china for military and economic
support having china enter the conflict
would be a significant escalation with
huge implications but as heather
europe's west explains the stakes are
high for china too
from un's secretary general the warning
was dire further escalation of the war
whether by accident or design
threatens all of humanity the prospect
of nuclear conflict once unthinkable
is now back within the realm of
possibility
and yet as russia's brutal campaign of
violence against the people of ukraine
intensifies worries that the war could
escalate into a global conflict are
growing
following reports that russia asked
china for military and economic
assistance something the kremlin denies
u.s national security adviser jake
sullivan met with a top chinese official
monday in rome it was an intense
seven-hour session reflecting the
gravity of the moment we will not allow
any country to compensate russia
for its losses would be a very
significant and meaningful move if china
were to switch from sort of its position
of you know kind of benign
neutrality towards russia to actively
supporting them in any different way in
part because imposing the same level of
economic sanctions against china would
be much more painful for the west still
backing russia would not be without
consequence if china wants to be a
worldwide pariah they'll back russia the
chinese are too smart to do that but the
fact that russia is asking means that
they're desperate i i think that
vladimir putin's back is up against a
wall
russian forces may have encountered more
resistance in ukraine than the russian
president had anticipated but russian
forces are slowly gaining ground it's
why ukraine's president continues to
call for more support repeating his
request to nato for a no-fly zone the
white house will now be watching china's
next steps carefully it says that while
china makes up almost 20 percent of the
global economy g7 countries account for
more than 50 percent the biden
administration warning china there will
be consequences should it choose to help
russia in any way david
heather yorick's west in washington
thank you
and the rising geopolitical risk of
china's close relationship with russia
contributed to panic selling on the
chinese markets today the hang sen china
enterprises index closed down seven
percent that's the steepest one-day drop
since november 2008 and the hang seng
tech index fell 11
wiping out more than two trillion
dollars in value
russia's northern neighbor norway is
leading an international military
exercise with 27 countries taking part
more than 30 000 soldiers from nato and
partner nations will carry out air land
and sea drills in the cold wintry
weather the exercise is known as cold
response 2022 it is a biannual military
event led by the norwegian defense force
canada's defense minister anita anan
will be meeting with her nato
counterparts in brussels on wednesday as
abigail beeman reports canada is
increasing its military presence for
training operations in the arctic
this is the first time since the 1950s
we've been operating up here in an ice
capable vessel
this navy video about a new canadian
arctic ship's first deployment
circumnavigating north america showcased
in a flurry of recent tweets from the
defense minister highlighting that
canadians are taking part in half a
dozen different planned exercises in the
north including noble defender this week
norad's arctic air defense operation
with 250 canadians and 100 americans
launching from variety of bases in the
north
intercepting aircraft that will be
replicating both adversary aircraft and
cruise missile threats the deputy
commander says the exercise sends a
message to russia we're watching them 24
hours seven days a week and that we are
so well equipped trained and integrated
that any type of attack would be futile
there's no accident that all of these
are coming at the same time that the
conflict of course is raging across
ukraine defense minister anita anand is
planning a visit to the arctic herself
in the coming months focused on security
as we look at the north and our
relatively low population density up
there
it's not inconceivable that our
sovereignty may be challenged russia has
been reactivating cold war bases and
recently applied to the u.n for a vast
extension to its claim on the
continental shelf certainly now with the
aggressive activity of russia it makes
us rethink then these other processes
that
were rules-based but perhaps won't be in
the future experts say the crisis also
highlights canada's sluggish
contributions to norad badly in need of
modernization we are the ones who have
talked the most about
modernizing and bringing up to date our
northern capabilities and probably have
done the least out of all of the other
arctic states canada will be at the
table in the short term with a robust
package to modernize norad
modernizing norad is in onan's mandate
letter defense watchers say they'll have
to see action to believe it on a
long-standing promise abigail beeman
global news ottawa
an anti-war protester crashed a live
news broadcast on one of russia's
state-run news outlets
she chanted stop the war no war while
holding up a sign reading don't believe
propaganda they are lying to you russia
has made it a criminal offense to spread
what it sees as false information about
its military invasion the woman was
identified as an editor at the network
and has been reportedly detained by
police a new round of protests are
rolling in
coming up where the next convoy is
expected
[Music]
global national is broadcasting from
ottawa we'll be right back in a moment
[Music]
another so-called freedom convoy is
taking aim at british columbia's capital
public health measures have already been
eased in bc and across much of canada
but anti-mandate protesters say that is
not enough as lauren pullen reports some
experts say this is a movement that will
not be slowing down and has already
caused irreversible change in canada
there are signs a resurgence is rolling
through western canada we're just a
bunch of people that want to stand up
for our freedom
three weeks after police dismantled the
occupation in ottawa and a month after a
border blockade broke down in alberta
there's anticipation a new truck convoy
may next arrive in victoria at the bc
legislature enough is enough we're not
taking it anymore that's despite bc
already dropping mass mandates and most
other covert restrictions april 8. in
alberta protests still fill some calgary
city streets every weekend weeks after
almost all alberta measures lifted there
are food vendors there are merchandise
vendors it is a festival
they say they're still rallying for all
federal mandates to be dropped but it's
also spurred opposition in the form of
counter protests in calgary
[Applause]
they were pushed back by calgary police
whether they remain visible or not the
sentiments expressed by so-called
freedom protesters are difficult to
dismiss away i think things the
landscape has permanently changed we're
going to get a kind of fracturing of
public discourse a fracturing of social
sensibility a common sense of what it
means to be canadian
and as long as public health and
vaccination remains a political issue as
well as a public health matter experts
say these protests will push on what we
can do is control
whether or not we
flame
or amplify those voices
and my hope is that we've learned some
lessons over the last few months
[Music]
bc and alberta's provincial leaders
stand united against more protests i
would suggest that maybe people could
find more productive ways of
expressing their their frustration i
would just say to these people goodness
me get a hobby
still the vocal minority vows their
fight isn't over yet lauren poland
global news calgary
new brunswick has lifted all its
remaining public health restrictions and
it's the second time it has done so
since the pandemic began people in the
province no longer need to wear masks
indoors there are no limits on
gatherings and those who have tested
positive for kova 19 do not need to
isolate and in newfoundland and labrador
almost all restrictions have been
scrapped though masking is still
required in schools and post-secondary
institutions at least until the easter
break
china has imposed strict measures in
some of its biggest cities as the
country endures its worst covenanting
wave yet
china recorded almost 3 400 cases in
just two days schools have been closed
in shanghai the city of shenzhen home to
17.5 million people is locked down and
so is the entire northeastern province
of jilin the provincial government has
banned travel commenced mass screenings
and mobilized 7 000 military reservists
to assist
just ahead with prices soaring at the
pump will canadians reconsider their
costly commutes
the national president of canada's
largest private sector union is retiring
to focus on his health jerry diaz had
been on medical leave from unifor since
early february just after an
investigation began on a complaint that
dyas breached the unifor constitution
the union released no other details on
friday diaz who is 63 informed unifor's
board of his immediate retirement he'd
held the top job at the union for more
than eight years unifor represents over
300 000 workers including many at global
news
gas prices across the country are
reaching new records today the average
cost per liter in bc is the highest in
canada about 20 cents more than the
national average according to the caa
this morning a long line of truckers
crawling on the trans-canada highway
outside of vancouver protested the cost
of fuel during a rainy early commute but
those prices have some people thinking
about cutting costs and skipping
commuting altogether and gaviola has
more
pain at the pumps with more likely in
store is pushing many commuters to
rethink how they get to work and get
around the ecology action center says
it's fueling a fresh surge of interest
in cycling from models powered by sweat
to e-bikes riding a bike is an
incredibly affordable alternative to
owning a car
based on
i mean owning a car or having a lease
gassing it up and like those yearly
maintenance
fusing costs this bike shop manager in
new brunswick says the covid bike boom
made some customers wait up to a year
for deliveries due to supply chain
snarls and soaring demand but this
latest boom is one for the books extra
challenging with inventory extra demand
and
products just kind of
being lined up for customers luckily for
greg quirk he already owns a bike his
employer in ottawa is leaving it up to
employees to decide how much or how
little they want to be in the office he
plans to ride his bike in some days when
the weather is favorable not only in
terms of being able to save money
because gas prices are quite high and my
car uses premium gas
um but just from the activity aspect of
it biking isn't the only option transit
ridership increases by about one and a
half percent every time gas prices rise
by 10
that's according to the canadian urban
transit association and eye-popping gas
prices have also supercharged interest
in electric vehicles with increasing gas
prices
we've just seen even further shift
there's a lot of people there coming in
and asking for hybrids right off the bat
hybrid schedules for workers are also a
hot commodity one of the top perks being
demanded in this tight labor market most
employees are well aware that it's a
candidate's market so if they are
inclined to seek other opportunities
opportunities abound with so many
proving they can work effectively from
home or elsewhere for two years and
counting fuel inflation means employers
increasingly need to be flexible in this
ultra-competitive job market ann gaviola
global news toronto
next up squatters take on russian elites
in london
you're looking at the national war
memorial in the heart of ottawa global
national returns right after this break
protesters were arrested in london after
occupying a mansion believed to be owned
by a russian oligarch for decades
russian billionaires have used london as
a refuge to funnel and store their
wealth but as redmond shannon reports
those days may be ending
they scaled the balcony and decided they
wanted to stay until the legal process
has been followed we will stay here as
is our right to protest they're calling
one of central london's plushiest
mansions home it's believed to be owned
by recently sanctioned russian
billionaire and putin ally oleg
derapaska the self-described anarchists
say they are occupying the seven-bedroom
building so it can be used to house
ukrainian refugees in recent years there
have been growing calls in the uk for
greater transparency surrounding the
ownership of some of london's largest
mansions to explain where the money has
come from to pay for them and those
calls have come to a head since russia's
invasion of ukraine various russian
individuals who have links to the
kremlin have donated to our political
parties here in the uk while mayor of
london prime minister boris johnson
played tennis with the wife of a russian
politician in exchange for a party
donation influence spans across
upper-crossed life here so we've known
about the the the activities of russia
for a long time and only now when we're
potentially on the on the verge of world
war three that uh the uk government is
is clamping down on this some residents
of one london borough say empty mansions
owned by foreign shell companies are
wreaking havoc on real estate and
affecting ordinary londoners we have 3
000 families on the waiting list for a
council house
and we have four of the top 10 most
expensive streets in england activists
are calling for more transparency and
better enforcement in seizing assets
where the source of wealth can't be
explained and hopefully in the future
then that those sorts of direct action
aren't needed and despite the activists
being arrested monday evening their
direct action may be working a british
government minister has now also
suggested that seized mansions should be
used to house refugees redmond shannon
global news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm david aiken there is still
much uncertainty for ukraine but we
wanted to leave you tonight with hope
for the future
friends marta and paulina fled to
germany while their parents stayed in
ukraine despite the raging conflict the
teens say they will return to their
homeland one day not just to finish
university or pursue careers but to
rebuild ukraine themselves
we are
not
soft people we are really strong and
we going to
rebuild our country and
it would be
revealed by people like me and polina
[Music]
thank you for watching i will see you
back here from the nation's capital
tomorrow good night
[Music]